hello you're watching entertainment week
coming up on the show the queen of crime
fiction patricia cornwell joins us in
the studio to talk about her latest
thriller
urban artist registry 2 tells us why
british rap gets a bad rep
we speak to the stars of the hunger
games about approaching the end of the
blockbuster saga
and be giving our verdict on all the big
movie releases in our film review
well this week further allegations about
bill cosby led the american tv network
nbc to cancel an upcoming project with a
comedian
several women have accused the former
cosby show star of sexual assaults going
back almost 30 years but he's never been
charged and refuses to comment well
skyriana mills is here with us now take
us through rihanna that the history of
these allegations yeah well anyone who
loved their american sitcoms back in the
80s will know bill cosby very well
obviously from the cosby show but now
the 77 year old is facing a number of
allegations which are coming from around
15 women we understand allegations of
sexual assault and rape now it's worth
noting that back in 2006 a case was
settled in the civil courts over an
alleged incident that happened in 2004
but bill cosby has never been arrested
he's never been charged over any of
these allegations and he's also through
his agent always denied all of these
claims now he's also refused to speak
publicly about them however one
journalist did try and ask him about
these allegations and this is what he
had to say
there is no
comment about that
okay
and and i'll tell you why
i think you were told
i i don't want to compromise your
integrity
but
um we don't i don't
talk about it now can i get something
from you what's that that none of that
will be shown
so what sort of impact is all this
actually having on this tv work really
well that was quite awkward viewing but
you could see that he he didn't want to
talk publicly he didn't want that
interview to be aired um we may not see
much of bill cosby recently but it does
seem clear that he's been trying to make
a bit of a comeback we know that nbc and
netflix had projects in the pipeline
that they were
talking to him about and potentially uh
moving up to producing those but for the
moment those have been postponed we also
know we may not have heard of it here
but there's an american network called
tv land and all references of his shows
have now been uh removed from that um
but despite that uh despite the fact
that he doesn't seem to want to talk
publicly about it we do understand that
he is doing a stand-up show at the
moment he's recently
performed in the bahamas he's also set
to perform in the likes of florida and
las vegas so it does seem that he's
trying to push ahead business as usual
okay rihanna thank you
it's time to catch up on the rest of the
week's entertainment news there is some
flash photography coming up
the academy award-winning director of
the graduate mike nichols has died at
the age of 83. the filmmaker who was
married to u.s news anchor diane sawyer
is one of only 12 people to win an oscar
grammy emmy and tony award band-aid 30
was recorded by stars including one
direction ed sheeran and eddie goulding
but there was no adele bob geldof denied
the singer was being snubbed it's a
complete nonsense all this and it you
know who cares who cares who doesn't do
it or doesn't want to complete their
prerogative a day after bono laid down
his lines for band-aid he was involved
in a cycling accident in new york
central park he underwent surgery for
fractured bones in his face arm and
shoulder
motown singer jimmy ruffin best known
for his hit song what becomes of the
broken heart it has died aged 78
following his short illness mileen class
took on ed miliband in a tv debate over
the mansion tax arguing it would hit
little grannies
and s club 7 announced they were
reforming for a uk tour following an
appearance on children in need now the
crime novelist patricia cornwell is one
of the world's best-selling and most
revered authors her most famous
character is of course forensic sleuth
dr k scarpetta she's been solving
murders and gripping readers more than
20 years and with more than 100 million
books sold and her 22nd novel in the
series just released
she's showing no signs of slowing down
delighted to say patricia cornwell is
here with me now great to see you great
to see you for kate scarpessa the 22nd
novel what is the enduring interest for
you primarily in keeping this character
alive well i think a lot of it is the
way her mind works because she is so
skilled in forensic science and medicine
and just in the deductive abilities that
really go back to sherlock holmes you
know using your mind to figure things
out
that just makes it fun to work with her
i don't get bored because it's it's
never a straightforward case it's always
her interpretation of something that's
going to be unique i wonder what your
take is on on the television uptake of
this because i mean forensic science now
in terms of crime drama is very very big
business a lot of people say things like
csi really bounced off the back of these
novels well what scarpetta did the
scarpetta series which came out in
january of 1990 that's how long ago is
it really made forensics
accessible to the entertainment industry
if you didn't know if you didn't really
go in and embed yourself in in a
building of laboratories and autopsy
rooms you wouldn't realize how
you can translate it into to something
that will entertain people because
otherwise it's very austere and very
difficult to understand and so she
translated she was the rosetta stone
that translated all these mysteries into
something that is now extremely popular
on television and movies and also in in
other books is it fair to say that that
part of your fascination with this
character is the sense that you have a
lot in common there's obviously quite a
lot of you in the character or perhaps
the character in you i don't know maybe
a little of both but what we most the
most important thing that we have in
common that makes these books possible
is the way our mind works and i tend to
look at things and it's my nature to
dissect them and try to figure
everything out i do it with people i do
it with events it's just it's not even
conscious on my part and it's
interesting because my father was an
appellate specialist he was the lawyer's
lawyer where he dissected the law and he
was extremely gifted at it and so i
think genetically i come by this from
his side of the family
i've heard from authors before the idea
that a character like kay when you've
got a really strong character someone
like rebus for example that they really
have a life of their own that you're not
really in control of them they control
their own destiny in the books is that
something you feel i do and that's well
put and i i think they're like children
that you have
you do have a lot of say-so over how
they live and how they dress and maybe
even what they eat but they need to be
their own individuals and if you try to
over control characters you'll squeeze
the life out of them just like you will
with anything else and scarpetta is
to uh play off my own title she is flesh
and blood i mean she is alive and well
and an individual in terms of how i
imagine her she isn't just some
reflection of myself you've got a very
strong interest in east london and jack
the ripper and the the history and the
mystery behind all of that
where does that all spring from in you
it's again trying to figure something
out that was presented to me in 2001
when somebody was telling me about the
case and i started asking about the
suspects and then i said does anyone
ever use science real science and no one
had so i said let me have a crack at it
it is without a doubt the most
interesting criminal case unsolved one
in the history of of crime and it and it
never that will always be true i believe
so what you think we'll we'll never get
to the bottom of it well i believe i'm
at the bottom of it i do believe i know
you know who jack the ripper was i do
believe it was walter sickert and i
think when people see the remake i make
a very compelling case for that more so
than than ever but we're still not going
to really be convinced because we can't
place him at the crime scene and by now
the mystery of jack the ripper the
legend is far bigger than the cases
themselves it's an interesting
juxtaposition though your view on that
is in the sense that we will never have
that proof
and yet obviously when you look at
scalpetta about forensics that that's
all about getting the proof well if you
could put her back at those crime scenes
oh would we solve those cases just like
that but they weren't doing that back
then they didn't know you could do work
like that with crime scenes in the
victorian era what is your take on the
industry the publishing industry as a
whole now because obviously things have
changed an awful lot with the with the
e-books and with the amazon take on the
market
is it still an industry you're happy
with do you think it's it's still
surviving and heading in the right
direction oh it will survive i i'm not
going to say i'm happy with it because
ever since i started there were there
were so many squabbles going on between
various publishing entities it's and now
we're dealing with with technology which
has radicalized things the same way the
gutenberg printing press did if you go
back you know even to dickens uh since
you have all the greatest writers coming
from right here i mean he was squabbling
about a lot of the same things that we
fight about today if you read about what
was going on in the 1840s and 50s with
him but we need storytelling and we need
words and i don't believe that's ever
going to go away i hope not patricia
cornwell it is a joy to talk to thank
you very much indeed
the russian punk band [ __ ] riot gained
notoriety when they were imprisoned for
staging a demonstration in a moscow
cathedral and two of the collectives
members raised eyebrows yet again this
week when they visited london and held a
meeting with an unlikely ally the
wikileaks founder julian assange
hint hassan went to meet them there is
some flash photography in her report
they walked out of the door julian
assange cannot leave it was an
unexpected visit by two members of [ __ ]
riot one that was motivated they say by
shared beliefs we have
more common debts
than we expected
what is that what do you have in common
with him
i think it's
basic universal things about
freedom of
expression if we're talking about us
and
freedom of uh information if we are
talking
along with the rest of the feminist rock
group captured the world's attention
after they were arrested for performing
an anti-putin song in a church
the world watched as they were paraded
in a russian court from behind a cage
at the time julian assange said that
there was unity between their oppression
he'd been granted asylum at the
ecuadorian embassy so as to avoid
extradition to sweden the wikileaks
founder insists that allegations of
sexual assault are part of a conspiracy
to punish him for leaking classified
government documents the band members on
the other hand are battling the russian
government when asked their thoughts on
president putin's early exit from the
g20 summit they didn't hold back
we think that
putin's behavior at the end of the g20
summit was very performative and we
believe that world leaders like putin
are somehow
taking this performative strategy that
puts your eye championed some time ago
but that wasn't all they had to say
about the russian leader do you believe
putin when he says that russia has
nothing to do with the current situation
in ukraine
every minute
so we don't believe and you shouldn't
thanks
nadia and masha say that they and julian
assange differed on some topics mainly
political tactics yet the biggest
difference remains that these two are
free to walk away hindhasan sky news
still to come on the show hunger games
stars josh hutchinson and liam hensworth
on the end of an era
now he's collaborated with some of the
biggest names in pop from ed sheeran to
cheryl but with the number one single
and over a million records sold wretch
3-2 is a star in his own right earlier
this week he came into the studio to
speak to lucy about his new single and
why british urban music gets a bad rap
lovely to see you now your new single
shows a slightly softer side than we're
used to is this um is this a permanent
shift for you um do you know what i i
like surprising people and um i
definitely surprised myself and
surpassed what i thought i could deliver
in the studio so um you know to to come
out of the studio with this record and
present it to the world and everyone be
surprised i'm happy is it a permanent
fixture
um
nobody knows unless i go in this when i
go in the studio that's when i feel the
vibe and i make what i feel i need to
create on the day
you said that you surprised even
yourself
i can't sing but i can glide so um
you know just recording it the process
is extremely different from wrapping and
you know layering your vocal and getting
layers around me and stuff so i learned
so much on the day
you've recently tweeted saying that rap
about rap saying our genre will be on
radio and tv the least so we have to
shout about it the most yeah why do you
think that is why don't we hear more
rappers on um british radio and tv
because in america it's very difficult
yeah yeah i think just the demographic's
different here and i don't think it is
the popular genre do you know what i
mean and um i think
the the records that the radio or the
television represent are popular music
or the most popular music even though
rap is popular but we haven't fit we
haven't fitted in that bracket as yet
and i just think that um i don't think
it's necessarily a bad thing maybe we're
supposed to be a niche but we are always
supposed to
you know outplay our airplay or outdo
our our tv representation possibly so
yeah
and rap sometimes has quite a bad
reputation i mean people flag up the bad
language in it is that something that
annoys you it is sort of seen as um you
know reflecting all the bad in youth
culture at times all the evils in youth
culture yeah it's quite frustrating at
times because
you know a record like six words i'm a
rapper like one of the biggest rappers
in the country but i've made a record
like six words talking about my two
children you know but if i ever have a
negative line it could be
spoken about more than this record so
yeah yeah and used against you and other
rappers yeah which is it's not fair you
know everybody has
have stays and you have to understand
that rap music
we're reflecting and we're mirroring
what we see or what we've been through
or the struggle that's what that's what
that's kind of what it's about that's
what it's been built off you know like i
haven't got this but i see myself
getting to here and you kind of wrap
your way to that position
you work with a youth charity and find a
future which is uh i believe a charity
that works with young people trying to
unlock their potential how and why did
you get involved with them i love stuff
like that because as a kid
there wasn't as many opportunities that
were open to me
and i feel like being in this position
if i can use
any type of light or anything i get to
shine back onto the future you know in
the next generation and what i liked
about the charity was
it it allows the kids to be very
hands-on so when i go down to the
workshops they're able to come in and
they say okay i like to rap okay cool
here's the studio we're gonna we're
gonna allow you to perform today another
kid might come in and say
i feel like i can construct or or um
i like building houses and building
things okay cool we have you know we
have stuff that you can actually be
hands on and build and i think that's
the best way because
you know uh when you're when you're
explaining to a child
in in hindsight like this happens that
happens it's quite boring you know kids
they like to be hands-on they like to
try it and then they're like you know
what i absolutely hate that so i'm gonna
go and try this and you know we have the
option of them doing that so it's nice
for you presumably to be able to put
something back yeah yeah yeah a million
percent i love it i love it if i if i
had my way you know i'd have like i want
to perform in art school and stuff like
that that's where i see myself going man
and when is the album out the album will
come out early next year fantastic thank
you so much it's lovely to have met you
thank you
now it's time to see what's on at the
cinema this weekend and the big release
is the penultimate film in the hunger
games series
you're all from the capitol plutarch got
you out don't expect much chit chat from
him capital cut his tongue out years ago
and no
it wasn't any sort of rescue if that's
what you mean
we all fled on our own
for this
for you
our very own joe mccall chuck is here
look does it live up to the hype joe
that's the big question well it kind of
does but i think it falls into that trap
doesn't it the fact this is part one of
one book the same as twilight and harry
potter and it does feel like it's kind
of trying to eat the story out a little
bit uh too much it's easy to be cynical
isn't it you could say that you know two
films means double the money but i think
it just about gets away with it here
just how smart it is you kind of think
i'll go with it but there's still you're
never wholly satisfied because you know
sort of the best bits are still to come
in the second part and i think unless
you're a steadfast hunger games fan
you're still going to come away a little
bit unsatisfied
by it but jennifer lawrence carries it
in many respects when you've got
cinema's most bankable leading lady
there haven't you with uh jennifer
lawrence but it's been such a big
franchise for the stars of this the fact
that this is the penultimate movie and
presumably they've they've shot both
parts
together yeah so it's the end of an era
for them it's the end of the year for
them and you know when i went and spoke
to him i think there's a tinge of
sadness there they're not sort of crying
before bedtime just yet because they've
got to go through that press all over
again this time next year i won't want
to give the ending away this movie but
when i spoke to josh hutcherson he
doesn't have as much to do in this film
and he was quite sad about that
i knew like in mockingjay one um i'm
captured in the capital for a lot of it
and and so i'm not really wasn't really
part of the filming a lot for that for
that first film and and that was sad man
like to be at home knowing that these
my best friends were out making this
movie and i was stuck in my
own bed with my dog which was nice it
was just nice
i mean i was looking forward to
mockingjay that's kind of the moment
when peta really turns and you know he
goes from being this guy that everybody
knows him as and it's very close and and
gets tortured and brainwashed so his
kind of
descent into that was something i was
really excited to sort of take on do you
take any notice of reviews
i don't i don't read any reviews or
pictures or
no because i mean if you start doing
that you you can read a hundred good
ones and one bad one and you're only
getting under the bandwagon
this is all over for you you've you've
finished filming haven't you i mean it's
just weird coming back to sort of
talking about this i have nothing else
to live for
i'm
the tears aren't welling up just yet but
this time next year
i cry every night yeah i cry every
single night and sometimes mornings as
well
double cry
your dog's wondering what the hell's
going on with you
yeah he gets it
i cry every night steve but i know i
have to interview liam hemsworth he
doesn't say too much in these junkies
situations but josh was very chatty
there yeah at least one was look whether
it's a good film or a bad film people
are going to see it it's going to make a
hell of a lot of money regardless yeah
yeah and one trailer i saw the other day
and thought wow i've got to go and see
this is get on up yeah the james brown
fantastic trailer rags to riches trailer
great music scenes but actually it's
quite a weird film has this bizarre
narrative structure where it hops
between decades and you don't quite know
where you are with it and every so often
chad rick boseman who's the star plays
james brown he breaks the fourth wall
they sort of look down the lens and
address the audience directly and for
some people it will frustrate them i
think because of that i mean i think the
aim is to demonstrate james brown's sort
of slightly chaotic life but you never
get under the skin of him in it in the
same way he did with jamie foxx and ray
or whacking phoenix and walk the line it
doesn't quite match those great musical
biopics even jersey boys this summer
which was uh a great film i'll tell you
what let's tempt ourselves a little
preview
i hate you baby
not the end not now
and i want you to tell nobody you my
mama
it's me and you know that ain't true
well
i never want to be no mama
but
you're inside of me
i carried you
i had you so i chose you
you've got to say it's that he's got the
look and the voice and the express it's
there to me
it's spot-on he binds the whole movie
together and yeah he's got the sort of
the moves there i mean if he wasn't
strictly this weekend he'd be getting
tens across the board it's a fantastic
performance from him uh in in the role i
think he if he's not among the oscar
tenders next year i think it'd be an
absolute tragedy his physical
performance is so good they actually
dubbed james brown's
vocals over the top of this you know so
it is like watching a great concert
movie but i think that the narrative and
the time hopping might frustrate some
people if you go with it and you know
it's great but it's two and a half hours
long if you if it doesn't quite sit well
with you you might be you might be a bit
confused okay quite how you go from
james brown to paddington bear i don't
know but he's been all over the you've
just done it
but all over the news because there's
all this confusion over the rating
yeah it was um well it's been given a pg
because the uh bbfc said it had mild sex
references and mild nudity as you can
see their paddington bear doesn't have
his duffel coat on just yet so i don't
know if that's going to shock some
people
i mean there's a bit of a fury over this
and they've now downgraded it saying
it's innuendo they're worried about mild
sex references where hugh bonneville's
character dresses up as a woman that was
obviously going to shock impression
impressionable four-year-old so is it a
you now then it's still a pg so it's
still a pg it's got dangerous behavior
mild threat innuendo and infrequent mild
bad language
that'll encourage a few more adults to
go and see it i think it looks fantastic
and they're going to be giving it a full
review next week aren't you looking
forward to that joe thanks very much
indeed well that's all for now but on
next week's show we talked to ronan
keating about trading boyzone for
treading the boards in the musical once
the real-life british soldiers whose
ordeal in afghanistan inspired a new
film
and angelina jolie steps behind the
camera to direct her latest movie
unbroken
you